[sighs]
[geese honking]
[goose honking]
Day two.
Ukrainian countryside.
Started really nice.
I don't know, 4:00 in the morning.
And then the religious
music started playing.
And I opened up the door
and looked into the living room
and the family was
standing there praying.
So
I jumped in.
Closed my eyes
and put my hands together.
[praying]
Your power, Lord, and glory unto the ages of ages.
We thank You for choosing us,
delivering us from our sins, death and hell.
Jesus, we thank You for enduring
until the end and walking to the cross
Jesus, You are our Lord.
Lord, bless our guest, Peter.
Bless him!
Thank You, Lord!
In the name of the Father, the Son and the Holy Spirit.
Amen.
Father, father! Geese! Geese!
Geese, geese! Honk, honk, honk! [singing a song]
You see...
You don't have anything like this, do you?
A guy came by today.
A neighbor
and he had this
little metal thing in his hand
and it was just sort of spinning around.
And
when it would get the right point
he would sort of stop.
And what they were looking to
do is find where to dig the well.
We have to
use buckets in the bath tub
and there's not drain in the bath tub.
So we have to bucket
in the bath tub and then
extract the water.
[water splashing]
It's like...
we've been carrying the water for 4 years.
4 years.
But we got lucky that our neighbours don't live here.
If they had lived,
then I don't know...
We'd have had to buy it then.
Family is fantastic.
Wonderful, beautiful people.
Beautiful, beautiful people.
Really cool.
Who is this?
That's a pancake.
And what are you doing?
And then Valeriy sat me down
next to the computer
and he played this video
or a couple videos of
blown out apartments.
And then he told me that was
The building
that they lived in.
Your house?
Yes.
My father is there.
My father is there now.
Here it is.
Today I was studying with Alisa.
Babóoshka [Grandmother]
Grandmother, right.
Not “babóoshka”, no. Bа́booshka.
Bа́booshka.
Thank you.
She was correcting my
pronunciation in Russian.
He was listening to “operU” [wrong Russian pronunciation] [English: opera].
He was istening to “operU”?
Listening to “operU”.
Listening…
To “operU”.
“Operu”, yes?
Yes.
Listening to “operU”.
He was listening to “Operu”.
Yes.
Right.
She's such a little ray of sunshine.
Such a beautiful human being.
And then Mark came up.
The little guy.
He's only two but he's got a really
bubbly personality.
And Max, Max really opened up today.
He got behind the camera a little.
Shooting some stuff and I
want to get him on this project.
To actually shoot some footage
because he seems super interested.
You’re my friend.
You’re my friend too.
First impressions of Valeriy
are he's got this bad boy look to him
with the tattoos
but it takes very little time around him
to feel the genuine
and warm side of this man.
[laughter]
Well, that's when the frog
hunting process started.
So we walked
down this dirt road
on this pathway down to the river
and it's a real
narrow river.
Valeriy was hilarious.
I mean he was out there like a hunter.
Like a true primitive man.
He had his little stick and his net
and he assumed the position
of this hunter-gatherer guy
and he's good.
He got up
and
killed these frogs and then
smacked them on the rocks.
And yeah, it can be looked at as cruel but
I don't know, we ate the food
within an hour afterwards.
Super.
First time a frog.
Yes.
Tasty.
And that was my first time
having frog legs
and they were amazing.
Really exceptional.
And then we’ll catch the lizards.
The lizards?
The lizards.
Yes, yes, yes.
Well done!
Now dad is going to poison them.
[laughter]
Practice.
You have to practice.
He's
got an open heart.
He's a very loving father.
And you can tell that his family
is absolutely everything to him.
It’s wounded.
Peter, I was thinking…
maybe I should leave everything.
Anyways, we don’t have much to lose
and go live in the woods
where there’s no money, no electricity,
no Internet, no computers
absolutely nothing.
But from the different perspective
what will happen to the kids, what about the civilization?
How will they grow up in a place where there’s nothing?
Will they thank us afterwards?
Oh, and then I walked
in the living room
and Valeriy was getting ready for a tattoo.
[tattoo gun buzzing]
So there's this kid in here that...
What did it say?
It said something on his fists like...
Like f*ck off or something like that.
I forget.
And...
He worked on Valeriy for awhile.
Let me tell you…
Back when I was in the army,
I made a tattoo with an image of death
When I learned about the Bible
it’s written there that if
a person makes the tattoo
with the image of a skull or death,
it’s called as the signet of the devil.
And it means that you go to hell immediately.
There’s even no chance to get to the court of God.
That’s why I decided to cover my tattoo
with the image of God, Jesus Christ.
During the prayer session
this morning
a new guy walked in.
And his name is Oleg.
And he is the well digger.
when they said they were gonna dig a well
I was thinking, you know
bring a machine in and
drill out a well.
I had no idea they were talking about...
Today we will be digging a well.
Shovel by shovel
digging this well until
you actually hit water.
Teacher, is it good?
What?
Mark!
Come here!
Poo poo.
[toy gun]
What is that?
“Aria” [music band]
“Aria”.
Is it rock?
Yes.
Or metal?
Rock.
“I love…” [singing the song].
Nice guy.
Big smile.
Real soft, gentle, humble guy.
I enjoyed digging with him today
even though I have to say he did
most of the work.
Alisa, what are you doing?
Digging.
Helping my parents.
Take a photo of us from the bottom.
And we will stand like this here.
Today was...
A very interesting day.
And what is it, my third day
out here in the countryside?
Yeah, feels like I've
been here much longer.
Starting to feel this place.
It hasn't taken me long to really
warm up to Volare
and we do simple things.
We go to
a berry tree and eat berries together
or walk to a lake.
Конопля?
Cannibus.
Yes.
Laugh a lot.
I mean I don't understand
everything he's saying
probably more like 40%.
But it really doesn't matter.
You like it?
Me?
Yes.
I have smoked so much of it.
And now, I don’t do it anymore.
Natural.
Yeah, it's just this exotic place.
Not exotic like the tropics of
Southeast Asia.
But exotic in the
sense that it's totally...
It's totally a different reality here.
-To-ma-to.
-Tomato.
-Be-ans.
-Beans.
Cu-cum-ber.
-Cucumber.
- Cucumber.
It feels...
This fish out of water...
Olya, who is my friend and is also
doing the translation for this video
She gave this to me.
I definitely feel like this here.
Things got picked up.
Don’t cut it too short. Cut it here. Over here.
Well
that was about it today.
It's just pure simplicity.
Pure beauty.
Pure connectivity between the family...
Between the family and nature.
Cool, the field…
Tomorrow is another adventure.
I don't know where we're going.
We're going somewhere at 8:30
and I couldn't really understand
what they were saying.
That's sort of my story here.
I can't really understand
much of what's going on.
So
that's it for now.
Until tomorrow.